un maestro selecciona aleatoriamente un
equipo de dos personas de un grupo de
cuatro estudiantes la primera persona
seleccionada será el presentador y la
segunda persona será el investigador
todos de los estudiantes a mediaron son
hombres
las otras dos estudiantes caitlin y
denis son mujeres todos los posibles
resultados de la selección de equipos se
enumeran a continuación y yo los puse
del lado derecho aquí podemos ver todos
los posibles resultados aquí en la
columna del presentador tenemos tres
resultados con amir como presentador y
de este lado tenemos a las otras tres
personas como investigadores potenciales
aarón caitlin y denis en los resultados
4 5 y 6
aaron es el presentador y las otras 3
personas investigadores potenciales acá
tenemos la misma situación para caitlin
caitlin con américa trim con aarón y
caitlin con denise y por último la misma
situación para dennis denis como
presentadora a mí como investigador
denis como presentador aaron como
investigador
denis como presentadora y caitlin como
investigadora luego nos dicen si tomamos
los resultados 2 3 5 6 7 8 10 y 11 si se
fijan están escritos con rojo 2 3 5
6 7 8 10 y 11 como un subconjunto del
espacio muestral cuál de las siguientes
opciones describe este subconjunto muy
bien vamos a leer esto ya pensar cuáles
de las opciones describen este
subconjunto y los invito a qué pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolverlo antes de
que yo lo haga aquí dice seleccione
todas las que correspondan así que
podemos tener más de una opción que
describa el subconjunto
el subconjunto está compuesto por todos
los resultados donde el equipo está
formado por un hombre y una mujer vamos
a ver aquí tenemos dos resultados donde
amir es el presentador y hay dos
posibles mujeres con las que puede
formar equipo amir es el presentador y
algunas de las mujeres de investigadora
aquí hay otros dos resultados donde
aaron es el presentador y hay dos
escenarios donde aaron puede hacer
equipo con una mujer
caitlin o dennis en estos primeros
cuatro resultados 2 3 5 y 6 tenemos la
misma situación un hombre como
presentador haciendo equipo con una
mujer como investigadora ahora vamos a
ver los resultados 7 y 8 aquí tenemos a
caitlin como presentadora haciendo
equipo con un hombre como investigador y
en estos otros resultados está denis
como presentadora con un hombre como
investigador en los resultados 7 8 10 y
11 tenemos que una mujer es la
presentadora y un hombre el investigador
si tomamos todos estos resultados
hacemos un subconjunto en el que el
equipo está formado por un hombre y una
mujer y podemos ver que en los otros
resultados los equipos están formados
por dos hombres o dos mujeres aquí hay
dos hombres dos hombres dos mujeres y
dos mujeres vamos a la siguiente opción
el subconjunto está compuesto por todos
los resultados donde el equipo está
formado completamente por hombres o
completamente por mujeres no cada uno de
los equipos está formado por un hombre y
una mujer o una mujer y un hombre así
que podemos descartar esta opción el
subconjunto está compuesto por todos los
resultados donde en el equipo no todos
son hombres y no todos son mujeres
así que no todos son nombres y no todos
son mujeres
creo que esto es correcto si en nuestro
subconjunto tenemos los equipos donde no
todos son nombres entonces tendríamos
que quitar este resultado y este y
también quitar los resultados donde
todos los miembros del equipo son
mujeres así que quitaríamos este y este
y el subconjunto queda formado por todos
los resultados que quedan el subconjunto
está compuesto por todos los resultados
donde en el equipo no todos son hombres
y no todos son mujeres bueno voy a
marcar esta opción como buena el
subconjunto está compuesto por todos los
resultados donde el equipo tiene una
mujer como presentadora y un hombre como
investigador ok esto es verdadero para
los resultados 7 8 10 y 11 pero no es
verdadero para los resultados 2 3 5 y 6
en estos resultados tenemos un hombre
como presentador y una mujer como
investigadora así que tener una mujer
como presentadora y 1
como investigador es un subconjunto del
subconjunto del que estamos hablando
pero el subconjunto no está compuesto
solo de sus resultados sino que además
contiene el escenario donde un hombre es
el presentador y una mujer investigadora
así que sólo marcar estas dos opciones